the jurgen experience
that would be a wicked fight vitor
versus anderson in boxing i'm in for
that what do you think about anderson
jake paul i love it if jake paul really
decides to fight anderson that's a very
very very tough i thought it was i think
they're talking about it but and silva
just got licensed in uh arizona so the
fight will probably take place in
arizona uh jake paul in my show at the
improv he's in the green room i was
talking there and that's right when he
called out bismay so let me talk to you
man want to go
you know i know you say you don't care
about getting validated from the fight
community stuff like that and i said but
you do and i said i'm telling you call
now bisping ain't the move he has one
eye and a fake knee he's retired two
fake i said leave him alone i'm telling
you that's not you not only that no one
would sanction it he literally can't see
it i'm sure you could get it sanctioned
somewhere but that's not going to move
the needle for you who's going to
sanction a fight with a fighter as one
eye listen they say
they sanctioned evander holyfield all
right yeah but at least evander only if
you can see and he's got two eyes maybe
he's cataract anyway he's big maybe if
it does he has
i just assume he's older no i mean this
thing actually has a glass eye i'm very
weird no
no he puts a lens over it to make it
look good he'll take it out and show it
to you he still has his real eye but
he can't even he can only tell if it's
light out or dark out yeah that's it
the point is he has one [ __ ] eye from
the vitor fight so i told jake i'm like
that's not the move man i'm telling you
it's not gonna people aren't gonna
appreciate that or respect it i said if
you want to actually earn respect go
france and say
i said he's a [ __ ] jake paul is
one of the smartest marketers that the
[ __ ] sport has ever seen and he can
fight he's got balls but the thing is
people think he's this youtube guy and
he can't fight you with the way he
knocked out tyron woodley
come the [ __ ] off
i i've said this multiple times we
talked about it if that guy was just a
boxer and you'd never known anything
about his youtube background he saw him
knock out tyron woodley with one shot
you'd be like holy [ __ ] there's this new
guy coming up and he's a bad
[ __ ] he's really legitimate
to your point if you can take away that
you know the perspective you have that
oh he's just a youtuber he's just doing
this for money sure whatever but if you
just look at him if you know who he was
if you showed him to you know any of
these top boxing experts like holy [ __ ]
that kid's movement his timing his speed
he's athletic how old is he 24. holy
[ __ ] yeah that's powerful work ethic and
how was he when he started training
three years ago that's it just like the
first time three and a half probably he
never did any boxing before he did
wrestling wrestled in high school but no
boxing at all nope that's crazy i think
he's been boxing a little bit more than
that but he's boxing with real guys and
getting in the ring with real dudes yeah
and i think you get a real sense of
where you are in the pecking order when
you do that like you're very aware right
of
like who you should box and who you
shouldn't box but the fact if he goes
for anderson silva that's ballsy dude
that's just silly just be julio chavez
[Music]
i know he's lazy compared to his dad he
was 50 and three legit multiple time
world champion survived against canelo
bro yeah yeah went the distance against
canelo and that's himself up [ __ ] him
up dude and maybe he wasn't taking
seriously i don't give a [ __ ] by that
seventh round he's like i should
probably should get going here yeah
still whipped his ass well anderson if
he just went straight into boxing would
have been a [ __ ] world champion